استتباع
لخبر قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي احد القتلى
ايضا هو اي قائد سريه الكتيبه
150 برتبه نقيب كما ذكر الجيش الاسرائيلي
علما انه اشار الى مقتل ضابطين وجندي في
معارك قطاع غزه اليوم ونشير ايضا الى
الخبر العاجل الذي ظهر على شاشتنا
القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه تقول بان
امهات الجنود الاسرائيليين يطالبنا رئيس
الاركان بتوضيح حول تغيير نمط القتال في
غزه من غلاف غزه ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام اذا الياس مجموعه من المعلومات
والاخبار التي يريدها الجيش الاسرائيلي ا
كان حول العمليات العسكريه او اعداد
القتلى والجرحى في صفوفه اضافه الى اخر
التطورات الميدانيه حيث
تتواجد بالفعل حسن وربما نبدا من هذا
الخبر العاجل الذي تحدثت عنه قبل قليل حول
منتدى امهات المقاتلين الاسرائيليين الذين
بعثوا برساله الى رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بحسب القناه الثانيه ع
الاسرائيليه وطالبوه بتوضيحات حول الانباء
التي تتح حدث عن نمط او تغيير نمط القتال
في داخل قطاع غزه وما يقال ويشاع عن ان
هذا القتال بات يشكل خطرا على حياه الجنود
الاسرائيليين في ميدان المعركه وهم يقصدون
بالتالي تلك الانباء حسن التي كانت تتحدث
عن ان الجيش الاسرائيلي قلل من الدعم
الناري سواء المدفعي او ذلك الاتي من جانب
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي الدعم الناري للقوات
الموجو وجوده في داخل قطاع غزه وهذه مساله
كان تحدث فيها ايضا نير بركات وزير
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي قبل ايام وان كانت قد
اثارت زوبعه في الحلبه السياسيه
لكنها حظيت بتغطيه مهمه على الاقل في
الاعلام الاسرائيلي وتحدث عنها ايضا
اللواء المتقاعد اسحاك بريك في لقاء
تلفزيوني قبل ايام واشار في هذا السياق
الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كما قال قلل من
ال الغطاء الناري المدفعي وربما الجوي لان
مخزون الاسلحه او مخزون الذخيره بدا ينفذ
وان الاداره الامريكيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا تلبي احتياجات اسرائيل بهذا
السياق ودع في اطار هذا اللقاء التلفزيوني
مع القناه السابعه الاسرائيليه الى تغيير
نمط القتال وعدم الزج بالجيش الاسرائيلي
في قتال دار في ازقه وفي مناطق ماهوله وان
يعاد انتشار القوات الاسرائيليه على نحو
لا يشكل خطرا على حياتهم وبالتالي القيام
فقط بعمليات نوعيه ومحدوده بمعنى انه دعا
الى الانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه التي
بات الجيش الاسرائيلي يلمح لها ويتحدث
عنها في الايام الماضيه وهذا ربما يشير او
ياخذنا الى الاعلان اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن اعداد الجرحى في صفوفه في
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه حيث اشار في اخر
تحديد له الى ان 49 عسكريا اصيبوا بجروح
ما بين خطيره ومتوسطه و طفيفه واشار في
هذا السياق الى ان هنالك
ايضا عدد الجرحى منذ بدايه العمليه البريه
قد وصل الى
921 عسكريا لكن طبقى بطبيعه الحال هنالك
فجوه في الارقام التي يردها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في هذا السياق حيث ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث انه منذ منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي كان هنالك
2159 جنديا اصيبوا في المعارك منذ السابع
من اكتوبر فيما تتحدث وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه عن عدد اكبر من ذلك بكثير
العدد يصل لدى وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
الى 3000 بينما تتحدث المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه والصحف الاسرائيليه ان
القوائم قوائم المستشفيات تتحدث عن عدد
ربما يفوق الان ال 5000 جريح في ما اذا
عملنا حسبه سريعه حسن حول اعداد الجرحى
الاسرائيليين في الايام السته الاخيره نحن
نصل الى رقم اي حوالي 300 جندي وضابط
اصيبوا في معارك قطاع غزه في الايام السته
الاخيره وهذا مؤشر على ضراوه وشراسه ال
المعارك وهنالك من ياخذ هذا الرقم الى ما
كنا قد تحدثنا عنه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
ربما غير في تكتيكه فيما يتعلق بالغطاء
الناري المدفعي الجو وان كان هذا الغطاء
مازال موجودا ونحن نسمعه في الايام
الاخيره لكن اذا ما اردنا ان نقارن ربما
مع الايام الاولى للعمليه البريه فهو
بالتاكيد اقل بكثير الياس كرام من غلاف
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك